hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica below
zero there's been an update to the game
and now that I'm not an idiot and I
actually know what the hell I'm doing I
just gotta go find it what am I see what
is that floating ball sack in the middle
of the ocean also my face still still
swollen but you know getting by doing
good feeling good feeling fresh just got
to get out of here
so somewhere in this great big ocean of
ours there is the plans for some kind of
a C truck now I don't know where those
are but there's also been some other
things updated the game that I don't
know because I don't actually read and
if I don't Oh [ __ ] ass what is oh I know
what the problem is Hey
yeah there we go that's probably better
it was probably running like a bag of
tits okay so that's that's definitely
better oh yeah that's that's something
good no it's not it's not good at all um
let me see something here I'm gonna
troubleshoot for a bit everybody hold on
what you kidding me excuse me are you
out of your mind okay I gotta stop this
[Music]
right let's try that you piece of [ __ ]
hi what you gonna do now oh not so bad
now are you just as bad oh you just
bagged a Dick's ain't you oh you just
owe you tip dick and all oh oh oh you
think that I'm just gonna sit by and let
you do what you're doing manul boom
let's go what are we doing here what are
we doing I'll tell you what we're doing
we're doing exactly boom this exactly
look like a dream like a goddamn dream
suddenly like a dream oh yeah like a
dream now all dream baby okay anyway I'm
probably drowning let's poke our head up
and see what's going on around here
whoosh hello stop that could you just
there we go so somewhere in this great
big ocean of errors is the plans and we
gotta go find it look at me in the eye
you know that we have to find it all we
have to do is find the place where it is
and then go get it you did is exactly
that simple hang on I need to
troubleshoot a little more I'm working
in the Bois oh [ __ ] oh god okay hang on
stop and suddenly we're back all right
now for realsies it had you know it
shouldn't be bag of dick
why should be bag of dick what's it
gotta be bag a dick Wyatt Wyatt bag and
it hang on I got stuff okay how's it
doing now is that better I think that
might actually be better okay did I is
it no longer bag of disks dicks is it no
longer turd basket because if we aren't
I'm gonna be very happy but if we is
then I'm gonna be very upset hang on
there we go that's better
okay we're all mm-hmm me know like you
what's going on there there we go smooth
as a baby's butt smooth this busy but
baby's bottom don't know why this game
is taking so much goddamn GPU to render
alright now we're gonna get along with
the goddamn game okay so there is one I
don't know for certain but there is one
spot down in like the Arctic area no I
don't know if they added any other
threats I literally did not read the
changelog because I'm an idiot I don't
pay attention to anything like that but
there is one spot where I remember there
being like a dock thing where there
could have been some kind of a you know
little little bit of a like a like a
little bit of a data box like a taste
box I don't know I know sorry for my
brain to conjure up maybe there's a data
box there also I don't know what else
they did to the navigation area of this
that's not the right words but you know
the map I don't know what they did to
change the map Oh dick and Diddley look
at this oh never never mind loaded in
yes hey let me suck you I I know it's
around here somewhere I'm gonna pop my
head up breathe inhale deeply I'm gonna
inhale various oxygen up here and then
I'm gonna smack back down and hope that
there's no don't tell me what to do
Karen I live my life the way I want to
live it Karen you are not the boss me
that is not how marriage works I see a
glow Oh what the [ __ ] is that what is
that what is that oh is that a whale oh
my god oh my god I thought those were
eyes oh my god I thought those were eyes
holy [ __ ]
I can't ride you now Oh suddenly I can't
ride you oh okay I see
oh there I go okay but I got to do is I
gotta find jankis and then munches yeah
my munch you know man and then I'm gonna
find this thing I don't know exactly
where it is you guys are big protect me
I don't know where it is around here
either because it's just dark or maybe I
don't know the area but it looks like
it's changed a bit ooh God
oh god there's so many of y'all are
there's so many of y'all I'm going too
deep I don't remember it being this deep
before it was kind of long the walls
edge a little bit but we're from there I
don't even know yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna
drown yeah yeah old news there Taryn
I've drowned many times before I know
how to deal with the afterlife [ __ ]
I was way down there oh [ __ ] there's
threshers hey bud oh [ __ ] I may not make
it there Karen why didn't you warn me
sooner
why Karen why where am I oh hello
okay so somewhere around here somewhere
no nowhere though I'm but it's somewhere
here like I'm not too far away from it
it was down towards underneath the eye
hey hey you know you don't know no no
there is that it no but close somewhere
down here
why don't I [ __ ] look it up why would
I not look up where the see how to get
the C truck that seems like a good thing
and then I wouldn't waste my time let's
go ahead and [ __ ] you do that okay
C truck is a mobile sea bass ooh a quick
submersible location deep search for it
oh god kill me kill D somebody please
eat me alive
hey you come on come on you want to
fight huh you want to fight yeah I'll go
toe-to-toe with you huh
go stalker I forgot you're a stalker not
a not thresher
I don't even know what a thresher EO
you're running like a little [ __ ] baby
hi you don't want to go toe-to-toe with
me huh oh yeah coming back for another
pass oh wow ah
we're going toe-to-toe we're going we're
going to fin to fin we're gonna nip to
knop are you I'm gonna I'm gonna eat
your bones they grabbed one of you no no
you don't young kiss come on you want
some of this
I'll take Buffy on Wow oh [ __ ] you dead
no you're not dead not yet anyway come
on I'm gonna you only kiss you're doing
casts to marry you I want to kill you
before I drown I'm gonna eat this fish
before I drown it takes it away from me
oh that's good just good stuff come here
with my last breath I stab at thee I'm
just using this as a teleport to get
back to my baby don't tell nobody I'm
exploiting the systems all right what
did I lose nothing cuz I'm a badass
alright so somewhere around here hey
they filled up my food bar man dying
sure is competing oh that's right I was
gonna scan for it because they've got
the scanner room and then I can actually
look for it with the cameras which are
faster and can breathe underwater in
dummy all right a fragment okay here we
go we're gonna look for fragments
fragment okay so we're gonna go for that
one first and more will pop up on my
interface as soon as they are discovered
goddamn I love using technology
correctly in this place Oh another one
I'm such a genius I'm such a smarty oh
my god it was right outside my base oh
[Applause]
oh brute shark you ain't so brute oh
[ __ ]
take you incus oh okay all right
maybe I'll kiss skedaddle fragment up
there fragment down there I didn't see
how many I needed scissors a fragment
here but there's nothing Oh what is that
Oh mobile vehicle but mobile vehicle bay
okay I need three of those ah that is
handy ooh found more okay so it says
something's there Oh something is there
oh wow something is propulsion cannon oh
hell yeah I might toss some fish around
it's works out good for me man this is
stasis rifle this is my god I never
would have found these I bet these were
here before but just didn't see them oh
hey buddy how you doing friend don't
bite me
god I don't bite me don't do it hey
listen you don't need to do it
no he's gonna get me ooh sick dodge got
that mobile vehicle BAE this is the last
piece for that all right so that's that
so there was something over here
I just didn't see it in the brush there
it is stasis rifle man these things are
just laid out here all right got that
need to get some o2 and then hopefully
I'm gonna find the rest of the actual
vehicle itself soon it's probably up in
here stop it man you don't need to do it
you don't need to do it not my cheeks
hurt real bad everybody give me pity
points dies my cheeks hurt real bad
Oh cue the dramatic music I still got my
wisdom teeth holes in my face the only
thing that can cure me is for you to
like this video but you know I know hey
Aquarium module fragment okay I don't
know what the aquarium module is for oh
I don't have any batteries I guess I'm
good manual mode now that actually hurts
more than just me not being a [ __ ]
where did it go that was I don't know
and it just vanished okay I guess whoa
whoa whoa see monkey I what are you
you're cute
oh you're cute donk oh you're pretty
cute let me get a look at you oh you are
cute Oh No I will cut you I'm cutting
you I'm cutting you I'll cut you I'm
gonna cut you okay you
I don't like you I need more battery
that son of a [ __ ] thinks being a
playful little scamp more like being a
playful little [ __ ] think you can
just take it like that no oh oh no yeah
whatever okay do I have enough for a
battery I doubt it was a Power Cell
for the truck for the truck okay do I
have any ribbon plants in any of my
stored sky fund yes I do
okay do you have are those dead
batteries are those those are dead
batteries okay so I'm gonna toss those
there
let's make us a battery to please
actually and then I'm what the [ __ ] what
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
cuz I can't get more of those but that's
fine umm lilypad resource I don't care
anybody cut copper here copper anybody
no okay so one battery is all we're
gonna get but one battery's all we're
gonna need because then we're gonna
switch over the power cells for the
other dudes but we're gonna be better
than that but it doesn't matter if
they're empty or not hope you guys can
understand what I said and if you do it
and I don't care hey I need to clean up
the back of my office is not to look and
do good ooh
is that what I think it is yes I do okay
I don't know if this is the second or
third second okay so we need one more of
those and then we need to get the other
fragment for the mobile aquarium
whatever that may be
I don't know why we would need a mobile
aquarium oh yes yes please and then
we're just gonna leave that is not a
seed truck that is a seamoth I'm it as
much as I miss miss bio whoa as much as
I miss bubble but I think I'm gonna like
the C truck a little better kind of like
a intermediary between the seamoth and a
cyclops which was just a tad unwieldy I
think we did we get enough for the
mobile vehicle day I do not know no
that's a that's a craftable in this
store I don't know if I have enough for
it on my half to go seek some resources
but as it stands I'm in good position so
let's get e to it alright so I need the
mobile vehicle Bay which requires Lou
power cell and titanium ingot I've got
some titanium here enough for one ingot
no probably not
I need ten silicone rubber I think was
part of it I need to get creepvine oil
for the
I honestly don't have titanium but I
need to go out and I need to get Hopper
anyways good thing I'm over here by
these but none of them have berries
berry
we're berry oh they're berry okay got
berry Thank You Barry okay I'm gonna
grab these it's a lot of Lube don't need
that much Hey No are you coppered yes I
need two more titanium anyway so this is
good yep okay that's the last titanium
I'm picking up though
copper yes how much room I got nothing
okay perfect let's get back let's make
this bad boy yo incus you want my donkus
I don't think there's a badass is I
think okay so I got some Lube oh one
each oh cool well I already have
silicone rubber and I know I'm gonna
need more Lube I'm gonna need our cell
which is two batteries and silicone
rubber all I need to do is take one of
the dead batteries out so I need to make
a Power Cell get the titanium ingot
which I can make right now let's get the
dead batteries out and let's make it out
of that let's put okay they're all dead
so all these batteries are dead put it
in here make a Power Cell and I'm gonna
need another Power Cell for the big
thing anyway
so let's make the mobile vehicle Bay and
then whatever it takes for the truck I'm
gonna find out as soon as I deploy this
bad boy Geoffrey Billy Sam ice and
Marshall are gonna be back who are
actually gonna be able to say hi to them
well receive really really really you
think really you think oh [ __ ] that
didn't I didn't do it
there we go hey Geoffrey Billy's
sandwich and Marshall how y'all doin
good good good okay so we see truck and
see aquarium module advanced wiring kit
times five lead-glass whoa Rufus my two
fish that's a lot of stuff okay advanced
wiring kit advanced wiring kit roof and
the C truck aquarium module alright okay
Geoffrey Billy Sam wants Marshall I'll
be back five Jesus okay I don't even
know what it takes to make one what are
we looking at here
advanced wiring kit or silver or so
we're into lost silver a lot of gold and
a lot of computer chips holy [ __ ]
alright um
[ __ ] well nobody ever said it was gonna
be easy I don't know if I have the table
quarrel I definitely don't have the
table
and I'm definitely gonna search for that
I have to lead exactly - no that's
lithium that's not even lead so first
off I got a search for table coral
that's first and silver maybe first I
got search for silver let's look for
breakable silver outcrop let's go for
that first cuz that's what I need to
make just the computer chips and I need
five of those
he's dork it's very dork silver titanium
lead a [ __ ]
breakable silver man these are strewn
about this is gonna take some search and
so cue the montage music I'm gonna walk
up cue the montage music it's gonna be
it's gonna be lit hey I'll double down
it's gonna be lit a.m. [ __ ]
[Music]
there's some table coral that's good
maybe that [ __ ]
well no no no no no no no no there is no
need there is no need
yeah there's no need whoa whoa there's
no need hey dude I know I got a
delicious delectable face but you there
is no need yeesh hmm that's unpleasant
whoa inventory is full Oh hot tits yeah
all right so that should be enough to
get started I still don't have enough
lead but that's gonna be next on my list
where's my face
come on base don't do this to me get in
my face so now that I got the silver I
think it's gonna be enough to make I
think this is the first of the wiring
kit that's yeah the wiring kits okay so
we're gonna make the wiring kits we need
five of these I think we have enough one
two three four yes okay so we got what
we need there let's go ahead and put
some [ __ ] away and get rid of that and
some of that and that for now not the
table so we need some more table corals
so I got to go search for table Coral
none of that please give me table coral
what we're gonna look for lead our eBook
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] okay so I gotta
just manually find table coral which I
tried that before and it didn't go so
good let that should be enough okay so I
need to I need table coral now there
that's table coral moderately easier to
spot now I spy with my little eye
wha-hoo
they warned me okay that should be
enough oh that was right by my head okay
so I got enough table coral now I just
need to get whatever the [ __ ] else I was
gonna get golden copper wire so I got
some copper I know that and I've got
some gold I know that copper gold do I
have enough gold I have four gold that
might not be enough gold might not be
enough I might need one more which I'd
be very mad at but I would get I
understand whatever whatever it's just
gotta be a pain in the dick all right so
let's make the copper wire for it you
just take one you put it in a taffy
machine you stretch it out you got
copper wire how does it take - how
long's is wire son of
[ __ ] okay I have enough table coral I
only need ten so let's just put this
away for now and let's go get some gold
so I got to go deep for that [ __ ] and on
the way I can get some of the other
stuff I need there we go got enough okay
that should be everything that I need to
make this truck now I don't know if it's
gonna be usable right away I don't see
why I wouldn't be if it would come with
a Power Cell and then all I'd have to do
is make more power cells which I could
do right now I'm gonna eat you you are
fun and dancing and free and I'm going
to eat you come on you oh you quick are
you quick can I get also get a water bag
can I get one of you water bags yo you
dance and you shouldn't have been dance
and you should have been run in yeah I
can't believe I can't make water yet I
thought you can do that at the beginning
before if you just like make bleach and
[ __ ] but apparently not now please
I need these beepers I think the peepers
give a little water if you eat them if
you eat them cooked anyway if you eat
them raw it's somehow for some reason
that takes water away which doesn't make
any sense in a real Rp situation that
don't make no sense
well whatever we're gonna pretend like
it's fine whatever
I ain't complete look at this face you
think this face complaint no absolutely
not absolutely not okay I need to get my
table coral back out it should be enough
and I need to make these bad boys and
there we go okay and that should be five
right one two four I need one more I
like this music
[Music]
are you kidding me I need gold for every
single one it ooh you are you I need
gold for every single one of these
advanced wiring kits I need two gold for
each one off I need nine more all right
sure yeah we're gonna go with that okay
yeah that's great that's just wonderful
that's wonderful
let's charging it 1% power left in this
thing I don't even have enough for
another battery I don't have any copper
for it oh you know no that's no good
okay all right I guess I'll go find some
more sure yeah
okay we're gonna yeah sure okay oh no
copper yeah okay all right okay wink
wonk all right that'll be enough and
some more of those plants if I can grab
them and there she goes she did okay
there's a whole string of gold over
there so that's that bodes well for me I
mean I'm not happy about it but it does
bode well for me ooh and more of those
plants oh I love it yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm sorry Karen I love you oh I can't
even make water why can't I make water I
don't know then let me make water yeah I
have to get bladder fish for water which
is stupid that's not that stupid it's
pretty smart actually okay so first
things first I gotta go get some bladder
fish for water burrell salt the dye or
whatever that's it real yo you okay I
don't die all right yeah cuz you do die
in this game uh-huh okay I'll wink long
all right well I guess the oceans have
been expunged of all bladder fish and
I'm going to dehydrate to death
you know forget that whole thing that
you could last for three days without
water no not here no never not here
there's no blood well this problem that
is a problem okay I don't exactly know
to do about that because either I'm
crazy or blind or there literally are no
bladder fish you know and I'm just gonna
grab other fish and suck the juice out
of him I guess it's the best I could do
at this point there's no nope oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I made it nice made it made yeah oh that
was close but I'm just gonna get if some
other fish and suck the juice out of my
suppose it's the best I can do cuz ow
was that cuz I am drowning or
dehydrating really oh I'm bleeding
no wonder work no wonder I'm losing
fluids I'm bleeding everywhere high in
fluids low calorie count okay I guess
that's gonna do I guess it was high in
fluids but that's hardly helpful that
doesn't help me that's I'm still gonna
eventually die from this [ __ ] alright
well that's a problem developers
developers there seems to be an issue
what am I looking at here what do we get
what are we dealing with titanium
exactly what I wanted yep so much on my
screen I can't even see what's going on
Gold yes I need a lot of gold Q epic
montage music
[Music]
i money's at seven I need ten well I
need nine but I think I pulled it out of
my storage so I think I definitely do
need ten but if I run out of fluid and
then lose the items that I've gathered
like if I lose all this gold because I
run out of fluids and I die I'm gonna be
very upset let's just try to get the
last of the gold and let's try to get in
the base because I think if I get in the
base that like saves your inventory just
gotta get lucky with the gold no not
gonna lucky with the gold not this time
yep okay how many is that Ted all right
let's get back oh I'm not gonna make it
I'm gonna run out fluids Annamma I died
oh [ __ ] bladder fish just don't exist I
don't even know if I can search for
something like that I think I just have
to [ __ ] deal I've been what else am I
gonna do there's no bladder fish out
there there's just not oh I'm gonna eat
too much and that's gonna hurt me all
right whatever that apparently that
worked okay so I need to pull the wiring
kits out of here and then now I can
actually make the wiring kits but there
was something else I needed titanium
ingots I think I need those unpowered
you [ __ ] fine limestone [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
there we go
what are we getting power now okay yes
sure sure we are I guess I'll put this
[ __ ] back go get some titanium I guess I
shouldn't have passed up all that
titanium I was a fool I didn't know what
I had oh now it's gonna give me all the
copper in the world yeah now it is okay
that's and that makes sense I know I
know I know there's no eye eyes ooh
that's an eye how many titanium I got
seven I think it was wasn't it like two
in 92 I might have needed to but I'm not
sure I'm just gonna make these this into
food for water any water there we go uh
let's make this into the tide no oh well
all right that's not what I was hoping
for you don't you hate to see it I have
nine really I don't know how many of
those I need I really don't how many do
I need Geoffrey Billy Sam wants Marshall
can you tell me again
how much I needed hello it hello what
what what what Oh Oh God Oh somehow I
under played it I have no idea how just
one Oh just one then I have enough I've
got everything I need
okay this is good this is good as
opposed to it being bad this is good
okay surprisingly shockingly this is
good oh I have everything on me so I'm
good all right so let's just make the
advanced wiring kits we need two glass
and then bought a ping bada-boom Bob's
your uncle we got what we need
shockingly shockingly look in my eyes
this is a shock to both you and me I
have no idea how this happened I didn't
think I was capable of something as
skillful as this and yet here we are I
am just as surprised as you are gonna
make the glass and the Power Cell I do I
have the Power Cell on my person
or did I already make the Power Cell I
have no idea either wait we have what we
need let's go oh I got a job for you I
got a job for you oh [ __ ] no I don't cuz
I forgot the lid nevermind
cut this out cut this part out got this
embarrassing part where I forgot
something
cut it out got it right now we're gonna
do this oh yes baby oh yes baby yes it
slotted pretty under it's not as I'm not
as well as I was hoping I'm a little
under a little underwhelmed kind of like
a EE little goober there like a tip of a
dick okay well it's a lot yeah it's not
it's really less it's really less
captivating than I thought it'd be
it is really underwhelming it is really
underwhelming and I put oh yeah it only
has one why it looks like it has two but
maybe it doesn't okay well you know it
seems that the aquarium expansion seems
to suggest that maybe you could have
more okay it's pretty cool alright this
oh yeah okay nevermind you know what
this is okay I like this this is great
I'm super into this I'm gonna call you
the thickness cuz you may not be thick
right now what is that do I have a
camera whoa what where'd that go
what is that what am i what am I looking
at why is that happening I don't know
what that is that's super weird but okay
alright but anyway so now I have the
thickness it's cuz you may not be thick
now but you are going to grow you're
gonna grow thicker you're gonna grow
stronger you gonna grow longer oh yes
the thickness is real and the thickness
will be seen someday I don't know why
that's happening so you better be down
with the thickness because the thickness
gonna show you what is up so anyway that
is all the time I have for this episode
I'm gonna die of thirst real soon here
from the thickness and I will play this
again with more exploratory UM's with
the thickness as we go deep down into
the dark depths I have no idea what
that's happening I think it's something
to do with the camera but I think that
might be a bug thank you so much for
watching and as always I will see you
next video
[Music]